Y
PHOE
PHOENIX.
>> ALL OF MY HEART AND ROLL IS
WITH PHOENIX.
>> HE HAS HIT FIVE STRAIGHT
GUARANTEES SO HE IS ON A ROLL.
>> FIVE STRAIGHT BEFORE THAT.
>> LAST SHOW.
GUARANTEE IT.
>> I'M GOING WITH THE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS!
GUARANTEED!
>> DON'T GET ANYTHING ON THERE.
>> ERNIE, STUFF IS COMING DOWN,
ERNIE!
HE MISSED IT EARLIER!
REMEMBER, HE IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT DIDN'T GET IT!
>> ABORT, ABORT!
STOP!
HIT THE BUTTON, THEO RILLA!
A MALFUNCTION.
>> THEY WILL BE DANCING ON THE
MEAN STREETS AT THE END OF THE
FINALS.
>> YES, THEY WILL.
>> I LIKE MILWAUKEE TOO.
>> I NEVER HAD BALLS DROPPED ON
MY HEAD BEFORE.
>> STOP IT!
>> HEY.
ANDREW BRIAN, I LOVE YOU JUDGE
JUDY.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO ME ON
THE PHONE ONE DAY.
>> STAY WITH US.
WE WILL BE BACK.